ok welcome sorry ah welcome to this
video playing am black against Gator of
fun in a 15 minute game bit of a rating
mismatch here let's see what what
happens the scotch and I've always play
this line here with with the check we
should be three now Thunder the normal
move ya like em go not a green age
former this this is a bit of a shaky
line yeah let's play 97 dead years so to
play a five later so castled and oh no
f5 at a later stage
yeah what about f5 here is this too too
shaky on or good move if he takes I will
recapture with the bishop and sound
suddenly all right f5 may Bishop g5 hmm
now it should be five min I take on me
for he will take Queenie for threaten h7
threaten his Amazon it's annoying what
about 96 96 attending 95 also not not
bad I want to play a five though that's
really the movie I want to go hmm
I probably on Bishop g5 can play em age
6 f five push-ups you have aged six take
c7 queen takes it takes a five Queen g5
so probably not bad enough and I don't
really like it that's a big have 95 the
lightest son it's nicely placed 20 50 is
actually allowing me to to to play that
now on getting the the bishop cannot
cannot be bad mm what now
maybe I should down should exchange in
place c5 it's not bad intending c4 and
maybe I can continue with the should be
seven even call I could have taken the
bishop but it's yeah on this I thought
that I have more than one good good
answer Queen age for you've necessarily
bad night c4 is also possible playing
against be too I like this move there's
also sets of a little trap if you place
at four I have from tweenage to Queen h2
King takes Knight g4 night xe3 and yeah
its opponent and the position well the
queen is not bad here anyway but some
just annoying white a bit and maybe I
can still play five
yeah okay yeah don't want to exchange
now retreating sir not exactly Wow also
shocking move really why would you a
weekend de Paul yeah this is frankly
speaking just bad so need to take with
the edge point okay I'm trying to
highlight on on emphasize his bad piece
place much bb2 with some attacked and
you have you need to react somehow and
to know Bishop a success was my idea
could have gone to ecigs as well but um
bishop asics has a very concrete idea
the idea is that in some position I
maybe even can play Bishop d3 just for
concrete reasons winning a winning
material gap for example let's say in
this position if it takes on you three
light takes I probably just win the beat
up on
he needs to go Roxy one and gaba this is
South this okay if I'm okay that's let's
improve the position first okay i do not
see voice can push a d3 and dumb and
ugly pin don't want to do that hmm choke
him maybe provoke be three I probably
didn't play this the West the best way
possible it feels like I should have
forgotten more hmm
it is to go to d4 you just weaken the
square yeah take this temple yeah
control that five if you take some we
really have this yeah we have this pure
monster night against against your
bishop scenario let's let's protect g6
so that you can never ever play five
with Bishop 36 ideas
blacks got a phone to serve helps to to
break down the structure almost all the
cellphones on light squares so it's a
very bad please sign up again I mean the
pieces in relation to the pawn structure
t3 is really terrible so I'm just
increasing the pressure here
yeah but what do you do now I'm now just
threatening to win the pawn and I should
I should really take it I don't like to
allow the exchange of the light squared
bishops but otherwise I don't make any
progress and it's an excellent and game
of course so just turn then just take it
and play a form threatening book be
three this is some nothing to do against
that King f two hours though this upon
just promotes if he takes and if he
doesn't take yeah I grab a three and
then I'm two pawns up
yeah okay let's do this and so it's
enough with c6 and d5 yeah this is
helping me actually a bit now it doesn't
really matter okay you will run out of
moose anyway
ok now the sheep on the street otherwise
I would have taken Adam planking c6
later and now the sea bonus is the
winner here King be forking default and
the porn on promotes checkmate yeah the
key point was the eff takes g3's capture
here he really must take taker with the
h-bond and then I like black here I'm
already slightly more comfortable
somebody because this pawn is is a
problem and I have nicely em position
pieces let's say he protects and play
move like this got rooked be 8 a-5 I
have a slide slide initiative but then
in the game with F takes it was just the
same but just much worse with the the
isolated e porn and the bed structure so
on Black is excellent here I probably
had had better ways to convert here 93
now the computer wants to play with the
win
yeah that's a good move it's a bit lame
what I played ok but it always kept them
captain edge yeah especially this now as
some just terrible you get completely
destroyed you buy the like knight on d4
yeah thanks for watching